il ya une bonne partie de l'europe
s'était transformé en fournaise
aujourd'hui ça se poursuit avec le
réchauffement climatique les
modifications qui peut y avoir et ben
c'est vrai que c'est ça fait un peu par
la france après avoir brisé des dizaines
de records météo voilà vague de chaleur
se déplacer de l'ouest vers l'est avec
des températures qui atteint plus de 40
degrés et puis de territoire français
continue de brûler des milliers
d'hectares incendié dans la région de
bordeaux 2000 pompiers en renfort et
plus de 35000 personnes évacuées
économiquement ça va être très difficile
pour eux est très difficile pour la
commune je vous laisse imaginer parce
que nous sommes une vie de touristique
et la saison nous en avons besoin
des grands incendies font également
toujours rage en espagne
alimenté par la vague de chaleur et la
sécheresse
oh
au portugal on estime que plus de mille
décès surtout des personnes âgées sont
causées par la température écrasant
royaume uni un pays sous équipés pour
les chaleurs accablantes
le mercure s'est maintenu à 25 degrés la
nuit dernière et a dépassé le seuil de
40 degrés durant jours
en fait selon les experts du climat
l'europe serait maintenant devenue la
région du monde la plus fréquemment
sujette à des épisodes de chaleur
extrême en bonne partie en raison de
l'impact des changements climatiques et
de chercheurs
tout indique que la vague de chaleur
actuelle va se déplacer vers l'est de
l'europe durant les prochains jours et
qu'elle se poursuivra jusqu'au milieu de
la semaine prochaine ici normand grondin
radio canada montréal